Hướng tới kỳn đẹp mấy 15 năm ngày báo nhân dần ra số đau.
Muy mua tháng 8, năm 1 in chính trạm nằm 1 mua tháng 8, nằm 2 in không trong 2 mi sâu,
báo nhân dần tổ chức cuộc thiện báo chiến hỗ trụ đẹp viết nằm trên hàng trình đột mới.
Hôm thiên em tuyên chuyện quan bá hình nền đất nước con người Việt Nam trong thời đại mới,
hàng tự về tiên tế xá hội, bánh hoá của Việt Nam trong 4 mua năm đột mới, bảo vệ chủ quyền đất nước.
Thủ hốt khi kịch lệ đông đạo lửa sĩnh phản chân nghiệp và không chuyên,
và không viện tôm xanh Việt Nam, tích ở tự nướng và tháng 3 dự thi.
Các bạn dự thi, báo đảm tốn tổ đúng quy định tại thế lệ cuộc thi,
gió bàn tổ chức cuộc thi bán hành tốn tổ, các quý định của pháp luật hiện hành.
Thôi xanh tổ chức vào đậu trấm xảy và tổng kế cuộc thi,
sẵn tác hành về tây tài, Việt Nam trên hành trình đột mới,
trong thời xanh tự đam anh in không trong em ba đến ngày.
Thôi xanh và đậu vụ khi kháng sáo nơi mang lình không trong em ba làm.
Thôi xanh nhật anh, tự tháng sáo nơi mang in thuốc tròi mạng.
Để nơi mùa tháng 2 năm anh in thuốc tròi mì sấu.
Thôi xanh trăm anh, tự nơi mắm tháng 2 năm anh in thuốc tròi mì sấu.
Để nè hành tổ tháng 2 năm anh in thuốc tròi mì sấu.
Thôi xanh công bố cái quả và lệ tròi mạng.
Tháng 3 năm anh in thuốc tròi mì sấu.
Để nè hành tự chức trụ xả ở bão nhận dân số bảy mì mốt hành trống hoàn tiến hành hội.
Về đối tượng tham sự cuộc thí về các xả, công xa Việt Nam,
về cả người Việt Nam xinh sống học tập công tác ở nước ngoài và người nước ngoài đặc xinh sống học tập,
công tác tại Việt Nam, thách nhà báo phòng viên trên hỏi bị đất nước,
có tắt thần mạnh được thương quan báo chi sử dụt.
Tháng xả tham sự cuộc thí không bị phạm có khu đình về đạo đất dịch nghiệp phụ người làm báo Việt Nam,
không bị phạm lực báo chi và các quý định gần hành tắt xảy người phòng.
Về tác bảm, anh dự thí là anh chủp trên đệ bản Việt Nam trong thời gian từ năm 2020.
Anh lớn, anh không sử, báo đam, tư chi, anh báo chi, không qua sử li kỹ thuật,
làm thay đổi nục giống và bản chất sự biệt.
Chứ thăm ra phùa khi nào trong nước, anh dự thí giảm kỹ thuật số,
phải anh có định giảm đối gí phê cở, dung lợng từ 3 mi cà bài đến 3 mi cà bài,
nhóm anh không quá người anh.
Về giảy thương, bản tự chiếc xảy chào một dài đặc biệt.
Hành giảy án, bà xảy bây, năm xảy xây, người xảy quyền thích và xảy phùa cho anh đương và phòng xử anh.
Hình cứ kênh thường, tắc xảy nhóm tắc xảy đặc xảy,
dự chào xảy chứng nhận và tìm thường của bản tự chiếc của khi.